[Music]
Mr. Loescher, thank you very much for being with us here
today. If we can start off as Dean
[inaudible] said, you have worked in many different
countries across the world and worked in many different
businesses. Perhaps we could start by asking you, there are
some common traits that you have identified with all of the
leaders that you have met that you would say define
leadership for you.
I think there are many, many definitions of leaderships
around the world so I will not be the one who will add
another one. But I mean if you think about maybe we can talk
a little bit in terms of what I personally consider as key
traits of good leaders. I think the first one I would say is
clarity of direction and vision. Second one is, and that's
probably a skill in itself that how you break it then down
in actionable steps shorter, medium and long term which is
then linked to the capacity of the organization and to your
competitive environment which you are facing so that you
challenge the organization, that you challenge the
environment but you make the possible, possible in the
fastest time what you can and what you are able to implement
so how you execute well in this regard. The third one I
would say is that you have to be absolutely passionate
because without passion you will not be able to rally your
teams behind you. The fourth one I would say you have to be
absolutely determined in pursuing what you have set out for
the organization and for me, the fifth one I would say is
that you have to have a true north for yourself irrespective
of company values or company culture that you clearly define
for yourself what's right and what's wrong and then you are
on to the field to play.
And on to the field you were as Dean sort of said the first
outside CEO in Siemens's history. I imagine that created
some specific leadership challenges for you, perhaps you
could talk about these principles that you mentioned and how
you applied those as you took over as CEO and President of
Siemens.
I mean who has actually read and worked through the case,
can you just show me by hands up, well I don't have to
explain anything o you. I mean obviously it was a very
defining moment for the company, it was very defining moment
for myself. I mean I was the 12th CEO in the history of the
company, the first one coming from the outside, and the
company itself was in a major shock. So the first thing what
I had to do is really to make sure that what happened to the
organization was never part of the company culture. So the
first thing what I set out for the organization to clearly
differentiate that we had a major leadership crisis to deal
with and to tackle with, but it was not a company culture
issue per se what we had to deal with. So for me resolving
this issue in the fastest possible time was obviously the
highest priority. The second one is then when you are the
first one coming from the outside in this way on to the
management board you know it's the natural thing, I mean who
is person. I didn't have a broad following in Germany
because I spent all my life across the world. So the first
question was actually who is he. The second question
probably was, will he bring his own team with him, will he
change everything what we have done in the past, will he try
to revolutionize the company or not. So I very clearly set
out and said Siemens doesn't need a revolution but we will
continue to have an evolution but we will do this with
speed, speed, speed, speed. So the third element was then to
tackle the first crisis what I really had to deal with and
this is this whole corruption case and how to make sure that
we deal with it in a extremely forceful transparent and open
manner and I knew that I had to bring in people from the
outside to help me on this one. So my first key appointments
in the organization were absolute critical and this was
Peter Solmssen, the Chief Legal Counsel who worked with me
in GE and then also the Chief Compliance Officer so that I
had actually a team on to there who I can really trust and
who can really work with the overall organization to tackle
this most pressing issue what we had to deal with. And then
you very quickly move on to really say I wanted to have 100
days, I wanted to have 100 days for the simple reason that I
wanted to really see as many people as I could, listen,
travel around the world, engage the organization from the
customer viewpoint and from the different parts of the world
get feedback, get input and at the same time work then with
my top leadership team what has to be changed. And then the
whole thing evolved around structure changes, leadership
changes and so on and so forth and you have read the case so
I don't have to repeat all of it. But the initial part was
very much making sure that I am visible to as many people of
the organization as possible so I had a lot of skip-level
meetings for example I made deliberate efforts that I made
big town meetings all over the world with being on different
sites, where I have met the young leaders of the
organization and so on and so forth that I have really an
interaction at very different level of the organization and
that I also get an input from the customer viewpoint. So a
classic day, if you ask me what is a classic day within
Siemens and I think it's probably still valid today and this
is what I have basically developed over many, many, many
years. I come in into the morning, basically start breakfast
with a group of customers followed by meeting with
politicians or with senior customers on contracts. Then I go
into having lunch with the young high potentials, me alone
and nobody else then followed by business reviews, town hall
meetings and then a joint dinner with the top leadership
team. And if you do this day after day, you get a very, very
solid and very quick understanding what are the true issues
and what you have to tackle on and what are the most
pressing ones, what you have to deal with as a leader and as
a leadership team.
And as Siemens has evolved over the last three years it has
400,000 people across the world. How do you affect change
when you have so many different businesses in so many
different countries and so many individual people who you
need to persuade and to get on board with the way you are
thinking about the company?
I mean the first thing you say is that you have to recognize
that you have to rely on many, many other people. So you
need to work one, with a united top leadership team. So the
first issue what you have to deal with is how do you make
sure that you really work with your team who you trust and
who speaks with one voice in one direction and acts and
speaks in the same way. So how do you quickly get basically
different change agents in the organization who are really
aligned with what you try to accomplish in the organization.
And for this reason the change that I have introduce in
terms of the CEO principle was exactly this, to absolutely
make sure that I had then the leaders in place who I trusted
who believed in the same vision, who worked in the same
direction with the same speed how I wanted change happening
in the organization. And then through the principle that I
have just announced and I am traveling 70% of my time being
in front of the organization as much as you can yourself
because there is nothing more important than the personal
and direct dialogue with the teams around the world.
And as you have evolved as a leader and if we broaden it out
just beyond Siemens, could you talk perhaps about how your
personal style of leadership has evolved overtime and as you
have encountered different challenges in the different
companies you have worked in, how has that caused you to
reflect on your personal style of leadership?
I think it's a very, I mean look at this crowd that I
always, look at all of you. I mean you are probably, how
many nations are there in Stanford? 50 nations. So you see
my grandmother is Italian, my parents are Austrian, my wife
is Spanish, two of my children are American, the third one
is Spanish and I am Austrian. So I have learned to be a
minority and I have learned to actually have a very acute
culture sense and this is very important because the world
is very different. And when you then have the big
opportunity what I got early on in life to work in Asia, to
study in Asia, in US and in European countries, you are not
just broadening your skill set, you hone your instinct and
you also realize that there are many, many avenues to reach
a certain goal post and you know all of this so I don't have
to really repeat it. But if I give you three examples, I
mean in US everybody knows that you can lead very much by
objective setting, vision setting, objective setting and
then you basically work your plan and the people will very
much align themselves in doing so. And when you then go to
Spain for example, do we have Spanish colleagues here? So
the first thing that you realize is that you have to allow
far more time for talking. So when you tried to align the
organization, the first principle that you have to adhere to
is that you allow the teams to really have a good talk among
themselves. And then this is how you create alignment but
it's very, very important that you give this, you cannot
just set it from the top and say this is what we will do and
this is how it looks like and these are the action steps and
I ask you to follow, because they won't. But you get a very
strong buy in if you do it the other way around. When you
then go to Asia, you have a very similar type of leadership
requirement; you must make sure that you engage the
organization from a bottom up perspective and then align it
in different initiatives, top down and bottom up. And this
is the privilege that I had in my life that I grew up in
different cultural environments, I worked in different
environments and this helped me a lot in terms of how I
appreciate the diversity of the world and also how to be
most effective in cross-cultural teams which is the true
asset of a global company like ours.
And if we talk about you have such a large organization, you
talked about the young leaders that you have. I think for a
group of high potential leaders like us perhaps you could
talk about-
But anyway this is exactly what I assume because otherwise
you wouldn't be here.
But let's talk about the other side of that. What do you
think are the most common mistakes that you see young
leaders in your organization make and what could we learn
from those mistakes?
Look I mean the first advice that I would have is I mean all
of you are leaders otherwise you wouldn't be here. But I
think as leaders being young or older the first thing what
we have to recognize is how privileged we are. And I give
you now a quote what was a great learning for me from Jack
Welch. I met Jack in the mid 90s through a benchmarking
exercise. When I then joined the GE organization, he was on
his book tour and I met him in his signing with his latest
books. So I said Jack I am here now in office of GE, what is
your one line of advice? You know what he gave me in one
line of advice? Peter, give it all, Jack. And I think lift
your dreams and make sure that you live up to the capacity
and what you have as individuals and make a real
contribution to the work what you do for others. And I think
this is the great privilege what we have, this is what
leaders have to think of in terms of what is their impact
not just from a economic perspective but also ecological
perspective, social perspective and the impact what we have
for many, many millions of people. And for me, it was always
a great privilege. I spent many, many years of my life in
the pharmaceutical business for a very simple reason because
I was enormously privileged to work on technologies and help
people to live a better life and to survive. And when you
then talk to patients and you feel really the impact what
you have, this makes me very, very proud of. And that's a
great privilege of being the CEO of Siemens being in so many
businesses, this is the impact which a big organization like
ours have is enormous and that's an enormous, enormous
privilege.
But I guess with that privilege comes a lot of
responsibility in leaders and when you look at these high
potential leaders you mentioned you have lunch with them
many days. I think a lot of us feel that we learn the most
when we struggle and when we face challenges, perhaps you
could talk a little bit more about when you talk to these,
what are the challenges that they are dealing with because
these I think are the challenges that we might face in the
next two to three years?
I always tell my team when I look into this room here how
many of you will join big global organizations like Siemens.
One, two, three, four, five, and that's the reality; you
want to become entrepreneurs, you look for very different
fulfillments in your life. I mean when I was at Harvard and
we were talking about when you go through the last 20 years,
I mean 20 years ago poverty was the issue. At one point
there were the big organizations then there was the whole
wave of the consultancies then was a big wave of the
financial industry and the most promising perspective right
now is to be real entrepreneurship. So making it for
yourself and create something for yourself and you are here
in your backyards at Silicon Valley, and I was quite
impressed. I learned from the dean actually
[inaudible] that 40% of you will actually start to work
there, that's great. So for a big organization like Siemens,
you are not waiting till you are middle aged and gray till
somebody in life will tell you and now you are fully
responsible. You are asking for the responsibility far
earlier than any generation before you. You also have an
enormous privilege like all of us when we compare the change
what is now happening in the world be it technological
change, be it the global change which is happening, it is
happening in one management generation. The type of change
which used to happen
[inaudible] so there is an enormous compressed way of
opportunity. There is an enormous opportunity space. So big
organizations have to make sure how they are attractive for
a young population like yourself who is asking for broader
experience and more responsibility far earlier than any
other management generation before you and that's the
challenge and that's the type of opportunity space which big
companies have to face.
And when we look at this next generation leaders, how do you
think the challenges that they will face as leaders, you
have talked about them having more responsibility earlier
but how do you see the other challenges they face as leaders
has being different from the current generation and from
generations before them?
I think as I said I mean the big change is if you just talk
about the globalization which is currently happening in the
world, it's with a speed which is enormous. I grew up for
example, in my first studies, I studies in Austria and the
Iron Curtain was actually just happening in the backyards of
Vienna and I was crossing this Iron Curtain several times. I
could not imagine, really I could not imagine that I will
ever see in my life that this would change. This for me was
something which was given and look what happened just
through this one thing how the world has changed. Now we are
going through a major crisis and we see all of a sudden the
political architecture changing dramatically going from a
G7, G8 to a G20, the emerging markets they are asking for
far more responsibility not just economically but also
politically. When you then look where 97% of incremental
population growth will happen, it will happen in the
emerging economies and they want to have the same way and
opportunity space that we have in our lifespan sitting here
at the university. So the change that you have and the
impact, I would not like to talk in terms of challenges but
the opportunities that you have is the impact what Friedman
was talking about, a flat world which is absolutely a
reality right now. The impact that new technology can bring
in terms of mass impact is in a way democratized like never
before and this creates an enormous new opportunity space
for each one of you and find your space, go for it and make
an impact, and make an impact economically but also socially
and community wise and I think this is exactly what this
opportunity space is.
I think in order to do that all of us have benefited from
mentors in our life to provide us guidance and to help us
understand the potential that exists for us. You mentioned
Jack Welch earlier; are there any particular mentors that
you have had and what do you think were the best important
things you learned from them?
I mean first of all I didn't have, I mean I don't go back
and say this was one mentor which was great. But you learn
from each one of the people you interface with. Maybe one
story which was for me very telling; when I was 27 years of
age, I joined a big German company called Hoechst at that
time, it was a big chemical company and the CEO used to be
my mentor. He hired me and he said look, start working, work
here six months and then come back and then let's talk about
what you would like to do within our organization. I had my
one page and I was clearing mapping it out what I would like
to do and this and this and he showed up in his office and
then he was listening two minutes and then he turned it away
and said I will give you an advice, have fun, enjoy the
things that you are doing and make sure that people you work
with are equally enjoyable and then everything that we have
written here will happen automatically. And that's a great
advice because never try to plan any career, never try to
chart but whatever you do try to do it in the best possible
way and then go for it, it's a great advice that I got for
myself.
And as you have become a senior-
And by the way, at that time, my ambition level was to
become the CEO of Hoechst Austria.
I guess you are perhaps now a mentor to other people in your
organization, could you perhaps talk about how you feel
playing that role now as being a mentor to that next
generation of leaders?
Yeah this is very important. I mean when you ask me what is
one of the most rewarding aspects that I spend time with is
really we have now introduced a new mentoring scheme for all
the board members, for all my colleagues as well where I
have basically 15 mentees all across the world with
different backgrounds and we rotate them every two years. So
they are mentees for two years and then they are rotated to
the next, and this is for me extremely rewarding. So I have
very-very closely and the mentee is responsible for the
mentor relationship. It works in different ways, it is very
personal and I try to provide feedback to them, give them
advice from my experience and also at the same time get to
know where their challenges are and to make sure that the
right steps are taken and that they are stretched in the
right possible way within the organization. So the mentee-
mentor relationship is something which is enormously
enjoyable for me personally and I spend quite significant
part of my time to make sure that I stay in touch with them
and that we have a continuous dialogue.
And before we open it questions, one last thing that we have
seen in the last five years is a much closer tie between
business and government. What has been your experience of
that trend and how do you think that's likely to evolve in
the next 5 to 10 years?
Oh absolutely. I mean it's absolutely true number one
particularly for big infrastructure companies like
ourselves. When you think about a big company like Siemens
who at the end of the day our whole business is
infrastructure at the end of the day be it medical
infrastructure, be it energy infrastructure or be it now
with Masdar City the next generation of the city environment
so all of it is really big infrastructure programs. And
there you have on one side you face governments as
regulators, you face government as customers, the whole
stimulus programs as part of what we have seen during the
crisis so absolutely and then you have economists who are
very closely linked between infrastructure development
programs and the political agenda around the world. So there
is a very close alignment, it's getting closer and it's a
very important one particularly for a company like
ourselves.
(Informal Talk)
[Audience] Thank you very much. I wanted to ask you what
cleantech opportunities do you see for Latin America.
I mean I will answer this question but it will start a
little bit broader because it's a very important question
that you are asking. When I joined Siemens, I asked a
question what is our cleantech portfolio and nobody could
give me an answer what a he cleantech portfolio is because
it was actually in the businesses. There were different
solutions but nobody actually looked across and said this is
our cleantech portfolio be it renewable or be it energy
efficient. So when we have for the first time lined it up so
I started in 2007 I asked this question. By July 2008 we had
for the first time actually developed our cleantech
portfolio and it was 17 billion euro, the biggest and
broadest cleantech portfolio for any company in the world.
In the meantime, we have setout an objective of 25 billion,
we will overachieve it already this year and we are by far
the biggest infrastructure company and this is what I set
out as a vision for the company to be a green infrastructure
pioneer. So that's the major, major strategic emphasis of
the company across all business lines. To make sure that the
next generation of product development are more resource
efficient and energy efficient and when we have the highest
speed trains and the highest speed trains are only consuming
0.33 liters per 100 kilometers per passenger then it's the
most energy efficient high speed train as well not just the
fastest one. And when you look into the sustainability
agenda around the world, it is blatant clear that this is on
the highest political priority level despite the fact that
Copenhagen has not succeeded to bring into any climate
change agreement. But, when you talk about to mayors around
the world that 1% of the population of square meter, our
city is consuming 75% of energy consumption, 80% of CO2
emissions, you know that this is the biggest challenge
around the world. And in south and Latin America and this is
all around the world. When you then talk about and you talk
about the Olympic games for example Brazil or the Football
World Cup, the big resource and the infrastructure
development programs which are currently put into place have
all the agenda of making sure that the latest generation of
infrastructure development is significantly better in terms
of sustainability of the infrastructure development programs
than any other generation before. So you have this, in Latin
America equally, for example last week I was together with
Pinera, the President of Chile, again we immediately worked
on a program how can actually Chile now introduce the latest
technology of cleantech to really make sure that they
benefit for example of their solar intensity that they have
and how can they bring together solar programs, that they
make sure that in their biggest cities are the mobility
infrastructure programs which are now built out with a
latest technology of far more resources and consuming less
resources than before. So it's a big, big program across all
political scopes be it in Latin America, be it in this
country. I mean Obama has made a big, big, big push in terms
of cleantech being not just being a big job engine, how the
economy will be revived; if you go to Asia, to China for
example, it's a massive government agenda. So you have it
all over the world and you definitely see it also in Latin
America.
[Audience] Hi. Thank you very much for being here with us
Mr. Loescher. A question I have for you is the following.
Over the past 100 years, the German precise traditional way
of doing things has served Siemens very well in developing
all this infrastructure that we see. Now we see a bigger
trend towards need for innovation and more high speed. How
do you manage to change that culture and foster this kind of
Silicon Valley sort of culture inside such a big company?
That's a very important question because at the end of the
day, in any company, 90% of the innovation is happening
outside the walls of the company. So we have a big program
for example currently what we call internally open
innovation historically our laps which we have already all
over the world, we have one here on the West Coast, we have
one in Princeton on the East Coast, we have it in Asia, we
have it in Germany, we have it in 30 countries around the
world where we have research and development activities
ongoing currently. Number one, the network will be wider
historically. Our research and developers have very much
focused their time on what is happening in their own laps
and now the focus is shifting and this is why we call it
open innovation that we make sure where is in all the
technology fields which are in our sphere of interest, where
are the big partner networks, outside partner networks that
we have to link with to make sure that we innovate faster
relative to all competitors. So we have a big push basically
driving the innovation agenda outside our own founder
engaging with big research institutions or big universities
or small companies and innovative companies to make sure
that we have the most innovative network available to us in
the big technology fields which are of our interest. That's
a very important push, it's a very strategic one and this
will be very important because there is nothing more
democratic than innovation process around the world. And
when you are looking to where big, big innovative centers
are happening of course it's United States but when you just
go by sheer size, if I give you the numbers right now, you
have just graduations, okay I am talking about technical
graduations; in Germany, we have roughly 45000 to 50000
technical graduates every year, in India there are 320,000,
in China you talk about 800,000, there is a range between
800,000 and closer to a million. So we see very much the
gravity centers of innovation changing, shifting and we have
to take advantage of the fact that we are already present in
190 countries of the world and therefore we should have a
very good advantage with great reputation in these markets
that we are able to tap into these new networks. And then we
have also a venture capital fund internally where for
example the fund is available for internal research programs
as well as for partner companies as well.
[Audience] Hello sir, thank you. You talk here about, at the
beginning you said setting vision and having clarity and
strong leadership and I think very charismatic leadership
but in some of our classes especially in OB we learn that
sometimes it's good to use the high skills of the group to
be facilitative, to be participative. So how do you balance
those two?
Yeah but this is exactly what I mean. I think at the end of
the day it's always the team, okay. It doesn't matter who it
is, an individual never really matters as much as any high
performance team and this is why I have also pushed for
example in the organization for diversity. I am on record as
I said the management is too white, too male, too German
when I joined the organization because I think you have to
tap into the diversity pool. What you have is a global
organization and when you have the great privilege that you
are at home in 190 countries of the world, that you are able
to track the best talents, to develop the best talents and
make them available for the global organization from a team
perspective as well as from an individual perspective. This
is a very-very critical element and we have on top of
individual responsibilities what you would be responsible
for, many-many programs where we particularly look into
initiatives, corporate leadership and pulling into these
initiatives very diverse teams from all over the world to
really help us to drive the change agenda. So that's at the
cornerstone of what we try to do. But this is always in the
framework of the clarity of vision what you try to have of
an organization. So the teams, they really have to work
towards the ultimate aim of the focus of the overall
organization. But leveraging the diversity of team, I mean I
don't have to explain this, this is probably one of the
great-great privilege that you have of working together.
[Audience] Thank you sir. My question is looking forward to
the next 10 years what is the single most important
strategic issue that you have to face as a CEO and how are
you gearing the company to actually address that issue?
It's the wrong question, I will tell you why. Because as an
innovation company which is an infrastructure company, the
innovation cycles of many of our products are going for
example for 10 years, 15 years, 20 years. For example, we
are now bringing to the market the most energy efficient gas
turbine of the world. The initial part of the development
programs goes back to the early 90s. When we talk about the
current high speed train which we are currently selling, the
initial development programs go back to the mid '90s. So
when we talk about the innovation agenda to be innovation
leaders in the fields where we have focused on in the three
sectors, we are looking way above the 10 years time horizon,
we really have to look into 20 years. You can look from how
you implement in terms of this the different strategies, you
can look 5 to 10 years but when you then say okay what is
our innovation advantage that we would like to see in this
area, the time horizon is way, way longer than 10 years. So
we set out as the strategic direction for the company being
the green infrastructure pioneer. So the pioneering spirit
what you have read in the case is very much at the forefront
what we try to drive. So there is a big innovation agenda in
all areas. There is not a single business field that we are
looking for but we are looking to really making sure that
the energy efficiency of all products going forward are
significantly more energy efficient and that we drive the
organization towards tailor-made solutions for big, big
customers for example, which are not in the forefront of a
classic Siemens customer. A classical Siemens customer would
be if there is tender, if there is Palo Alto or anywhere
else and they would say there is a great train that we would
now like to develop and there is a tender process and then
we would be off and running going after the tender. But to
engage Masdar City and to say what can we drive together to
help you to implement division of a CO2 free city
environment and what can we from a technology perspective
implement to link together the energy smart grid
infrastructure with the smart building infrastructure that
all the energy consumption which is happening in the city is
able to communicate with each other and being optimized in
terms of the energy efficiency of buildings, of energy flows
across the city and therefore ultimately helps to drive
massively down the energy costs of Masdar City. This is an
innovation partnership what we are now pulling together with
Masdar City. Classically speaking, there is no tender in
this context but as I said a big, big strategic alliance
where we work together with Masdar City to really drive it
and that's at the forefront what Siemens is all about or
Desertec where we basically try to harness the sun of Africa
not just for the African countries themselves but also
ultimately being available for importing towards Europe is a
big vision which is 10 to 15 years out where we work with an
innovation partnership together with the governments of
Africa and with the European Union what is the right funding
which is required, what is the technology which is already
today available, High Voltage Direct Current technology so
that we can transmit energy without any losses over long
periods of time. So the big, big programs which are
infrastructure programs going beyond one customer much more
into a strategic alliance and innovation partnership is the
big, big lever for the organization going forward and this
is where we drive the strategic impact of Siemens versus
just selling products and services and being attentive to
tenders which we ultimately obviously have to do in all our
business lines.
[Audience] Sir, a quick follow up question. I see that
vision, can you talk to us just quickly about how you
translate that vision into execution by breaking it down for
those--?
So the vision Masdar City was a vision of the Abu Dhabi
Government. So I engaged very much at the top level of the
political environment of Abu Dhabi to say let's pull
together a small team of your people who are responsible for
Masdar City under the leadership Dr. Sultan who is the CEO
of Masdar City and our team. So, the two of us then pulled
an operational team together of creating a strategic
alignment. We worked for 18 months because you have to
really break it down what are the requirements of the city,
how is the layout of the city, what are the different steps
of phase one and phase two, it's now slightly delayed
because of the impact of the current crisis but they are
continuing with the vision. So we worked for 18 months and a
week ago I was able to sign it in London. This is how we
have worked and broken it down within a very specific
initiative ultimately being able to be signed.
[Audience] You said earlier one of your five values of
leadership was to have a true north that transcends company
values, company norms. Could you talk to us about your true
north how you came to that true north and why that is your
true north?
I think this comes back, I say true north because it goes
back, the first environment where you really learn about it
are the values within your family. And the first role model
for me personally was my own father. And then you have a lot
of opportunities and privileges for a university like
Stanford University where you probably have lot of
leaderships in terms of ethics, ethical behavior and
business ethics. And I for this reason for example have
actually sponsored also an educational initiative at the
Technical University of Munich to really provide these
aspects at the university level because at the end of the
day this goes back to families, the values of the families
and the values of the education that you were brought up
with. And then many of you I assure you, many of you in your
life will be faced in one way or another to make a personal
decision do I do something or I don't in different contexts
you know sometimes cultural norms and then you have to say
no, I live up to my own standards with my own norm and I am
not willing to go for it. For example, this whole bribery
case in Siemens; when you read the testimonies of people
this is why I say this was a leadership crisis, this was not
the cultural crisis of the community but this was a
leadership attitude of some leaders who have decided a red
line for me is not a red line. And when you then look into
the testimonies that they have given, the classical
testimony is well I have done it to the benefit of the
company. Come on. People were pursuing this because they had
sales incentives as well and ultimately they had made the
incentive schemes. So this is what I mean, you don't have to
talk about company values, this is the next level that you
then have obviously and I would very much encourage you
whatever organization you join make sure how are the company
values not as values but how are they actually lived, who
are the role models of the organization and who are the role
models of leaders and can you relate to them. And if
somebody asks you the most dangerous thing that you will
encounter is I have to do things because everybody does, and
it's up to each one of you to decide to say no I don't do
it. And this is what I mean by true north, I have also
encountered this in my professional life for sure.
[Audience] Sir, you spoke about how young people are asking
for more responsibility at an earlier age. For that model to
work that means young people have to be able to accept and
succeed with this more responsibility. So I wonder from your
point of view do you believe that the skills and abilities
of young people are changing commensurately with their
changes and expectations and desires?
What do you think about you here?
[Audience] I think it comes back to your point about feeling
privileged and I think sometimes it's important to recognize
when we are feeling privileged and so sometimes this leads
to an expectation that we deserve more. But I also feel and
I am biased that we are capable of doing great things. So I
wonder from an executive's point of view how you look at
young talent that come into your company and hunger for the
next step that are two steps ahead of them and are they
ready for that?
I watch very closely one thing, I watch very closely in
terms of how people are performing in their current jobs and
my alarm bells are going on if people continuously talk
about the next step. In some instances it's probably very
right and then the question is, is the person in a job who
is too small for him or is he able to actually stretch
himself or herself at the higher level. That is very
dangerous. If you try to do things where you do things with
the anticipation, I have a right of this and that and that,
and this is a very, very valuable question what you ask, a
very important one and to find the right balance can only be
given at an individual basis. But never look out doing
things in a certain way today because I expect something
from the organization tomorrow. I think this can never work
and will never work. Rather, try to look into finding an
environment where you have a mentorship and a leadership
environment where you can engage yourself and leverage
yourself early on as part of a great performing team.
Because early on in life the biggest lever that you have is
the high performance team aspect which was asked earlier
here. It's not individual, it's actually the team
environment and then you will drive on it. The question can
only be asked individually but it's a very, very important
question that you have asked.
[Audience, inaudible]
The Stuxnet is a great business opportunity because now many
industrial companies have realized the danger of being
actually part of a portable computer or of a computer
environment. And we produce in our automation control
division actually proprietary solutions and since Stuxnet
has hit, the drive to the little bit more expensive
proprietary solutions from Siemens, the demand is going up.
But it's a serious danger. I mean you have now asked about
the danger, absolutely it's a danger there is no question.
And we have now more and more customers who are looking into
their industrial control environments to really make sure
where are weak points so we are doing a lot of so-called
health checks for many of our customers at this moment in
time because this has obviously created a much heightened
awareness compared to before.
I would like to say thank you very much for attending
[inaudible] today, we really appreciate you doing that.